dazu jetzt die mitglieder des
haushaltsausschusses
aufgereiht nach den mitgliedsparteien
wir wissen welch schwierige ausgangslage
wir insgesamt sind wir haben eine starke
inflation die sich insbesondere bei den
energiepreisen bemerkbar macht auf der
einen seite und wir kriegen langsam
rezessive tendenzen in der wirtschaft
also die typischen anzeichen für eine
stagnation und an der stelle meinen wir
dass das was die regierung bisher auf
den weg gebracht hat da nicht sehr
wirkungsvoll ist er verpufft im
augenblick und trotzdem viel kostet und
deshalb haben wir die regierung einen
gegenvorschlag gemacht auch vor dem
hintergrund dass wir er nimmt nur dabei
unterstützen im nächsten jahr die
schuldenbremse einzuhalten und wir sind
der meinung dass wir schon mit diesem
haushalt anfangen müssen da erste
zeichen zu setzen wir haben gestern
abend ein entlastungspaket in einem
umfang von 40 milliarden euro
vorgeschlagen
beinhaltet zum einen dem abbau der
kalten progression
und ein inflationsausgleich wir haben
die energiepreis pauschale von 300 euro
auf die gruppen konzentriert die bisher
nicht davon profitieren also studenten
rentner an der stelle wir wollen weil
der stromsteuer was tun die soll auf den
eu mindestsatz abgesenkt werden der
familienzuschuss wird würde von uns noch
einmal von 100 auf 200 euro erhöht der
entlastungsbetrag für alleinerziehende
von 4 auf 5000 euro genauso wie wir den
heizkostenzuschuss verdoppeln wollen und
das ist wie für mich jemand der aus dem
ländlichen räumen kommt sehr wichtig wir
wollen die pendlerpauschale auf dem
ersten kilometer erhöhen und nicht erst
ab dem 21 1 kilometer zudem haben wir
die wegfall des solidaritätszuschlages
vorgeschlagen so dass es insgesamt ein
riesenpaket ausmacht an der stelle wir
haben natürlich auch
einsparvorschläge auf der anderen seite
gemacht die rabattaktion 994 also dieses
ticket was wir heute auch im bundesrat
ist in unseren augen teuer erkauft und
und wenig produktiv an der stelle für
die leute die im städtischen bereich
wohnen ist es eine sparmassnahme denn
sie fahren überwiegend schon mit dem
öpnv im ländlichen raum ist es schön
aber gibt es kein angebot und insofern
glauben wir dass es nur ganz wenige
trifft die wir eigentlich damit
beglücken wollten nämlich diejenigen die
aufgrund hoher energiepreise jetzt auch
in den öpnv umsteigen also werden gerne
diesen leuten über die steuerjahres
fahrkarte schenken können das wäre
effektiver gewesen als jetzt in der
sommerpause leuten günstige
urlaubsfahrten zu bieten das sind
alleine 25 milliarden die der bund dafür
aufwendet und man hört ja dass die
länder noch irgendetwas damit dem bund
noch zusätzlich ausgehandelt haben das
müssen wir auch noch mal oben
draufsetzen und wenn man das mal
durchrechnen bleiben wir mal bei den 2,5
milliarden durch die 280 millionen
menschen in deutschland dann kostet
dieses ticket schon jedem 30 euro und
bei drei mal neun euro sind wir dann bei
60 euro das wäre eigentlich das wenn man
das ehrlich mit den leuten meinen würde
was man da noch sagen würde das war eine
lange sitzung nacht vor allen dingen gab
es auch noch mal etliche umfangreiche
veränderungen im haushalt
und vielleicht einige grundsätzliche
bemerkungen
christian lindner der
bundesfinanzminister ist als markt
liberaler politiker kein steuermann und
ich finde dass es in krisenzeiten die
schlechteste personalbesetzung die man
sich vorstellen kann denn
steuergerechtigkeit ist für ihn ein
fremdwort
wir sind ja in einer situation dass wir
im dauer krisen modus leben und wir
werden auch nicht so schnell rauskommen
wir haben eine explosive mischung von
krisen energiekrise klimakrise corona
krise verteilungs krise und den krieg in
der ukraine und für uns als linke ist es
wichtig dass wir die aufmerksamkeit
darauf lenken dass alle diese krisen
arme menschen besonders hart treffen und
darum brauchen wir eine schnelle
finanzielle entlastung der menschen eben
nicht zu den wenigen oligarchen und
weill gesellschaft gehören jetzt ist
gerade gestern abend im bundes tag ein
entlastungspaket beschlossen worden das
ist aber zusammen auch mit dem oster
paket ein tropfen auf den heißen stein
und da brauchen wir wirklich
verbesserungen auf der anderen seite
steht dass wir den eindruck haben dass
jetzt die aufrüstung der bundeswehr das
wichtigste thema in dieser
legislaturperiode sein wird da
sondervermögen bundeswehr ist zwar kein
bestandteil des haushaltes 2022 aber
auch wenn wir uns nur auf die regulären
rüstungsausgaben konzentrieren dann
betrifft der rüstungs haushalt mit 50,3
milliarden euro alle bisherigen milch
herausgaben und da ist natürlich klar
dass ökologische und soziale themen in
den hintergrund getreten sind die
koalition ist mit viel versprechen
angetreten aber wichtige fragen sind
noch mal angefasst also für uns als
linke ist zum beispiel auch die
unterstützung eigentlich der
kindergrundsicherung ein wichtiges
herzensthema im augenblick arbeiten
daran sechs ministerien und wenn sechs
ministerien an einem projekt arbeiten
dann besagt alle erfahrung dass das
entweder sehr sehr lange dauern wird am
schlimmsten fall überhaupt nicht
zustande kommt der neue bundeshaushalt
22 hat fast 500 milliarden euro
ausgabevolumen bei
140 milliarden euro schulden seit
ziemlich genau sechs stunden ist jetzt
unter dach und fach
28 prozent schuldenquote das ist schon
gigantisch
unglaublich hoch sechs mal höher als die
ausnahme die ausnahmeklausel des
grundgesetzes zu lassen würde
beziehungsweise die schuldenbremse zu
lassen würde ohne die ausnahmeklauseln
insofern macht lindner da weiter wo sein
vorgänger scholz damals noch als
finanzminister auch aufgehört hat
mehrere haushalte nacheinander trotzdem
sollte man sich an diese schulden
volumina nicht gewöhnen auch nicht in
außergewöhnlichen zeiten natürlich haben
wir das jetzt auch wieder heute nacht
ziemlich oft gehört
dazu aber dann gleich mehr es wäre
möglich
im praktisch schuldenfrei zu fahren
diesen haushalt wäre möglich denn es
wurden wieder einmal meiner meinung nach
verfassungswidrig rücklagen aufgestockt
aus verschuldung was sage ich überhaupt
nicht geht auf der einen seite das geld
aufnehmen weil es halt gerade geht die
schuldenbremse ist ja ausgesetzt im
aktiv ja ein bisschen rücklagen
reinzustecken auch dass eine unsicheres
der vorgängerregierung die jetzt hier
noch weitergeführt wird das führt zb
beim energie und klimafonds zu riesigen
rücklagen von bis zu 84 85 milliarden
diese auf die in dieser form gar nicht
entstehen dürfen und natürlich jetzt
auch nicht genutzt werden das ist eine
sparkasse für künftige jahre für ja da
streiten sich jetzt die geister co2
ideologie in erster linie
die asyl rücklage ist auch weiterhin
unangetastet die ehemalige asyl tage
heißt nur noch allgemeine rücklage auf
fast 50 milliarden und dann ist der
einzelplan des
gesundheitsministeriums unglaublich
aufgewachsen gegenüber der vor kurzer
zeit hat er sich fast verdreifacht er
hat sich verdreifacht
das ist waren relativ mittlerer
mittelgroßer haushalt und ist jetzt auf
über 50 milliarden angewachsen
davon mehr als die hälfte corona auf von
corona ausgaben die in dieser form
sicher im jahr 22 unseres erachtens
nicht mehr nötig wären ja ältester
dienstältester jetzt kann ich also noch
sagen dass meine erste
bereinigungssitzung im jahre 2003 war
und ich sagen muss dass ich da schon
sehr viel erlebt habe aber durch unsere
kollegiale zusammenarbeit wir in dem
ausschuss als koalition auch sehr schön
zeigen konnten wie wir detailliert mit
vielen änderungen dann am ende das
umsetzen was im koalitionsvertrag steht
wir haben und das möchte ich auch
nochmals dank sagen eben nicht den
fehler gemacht dass wir meinen dass
haushälter nochmal neue
koalitionsverhandlungen führen zu müssen
sondern geguckt wie wir die einzelnen
punkte des koalitionsvertrags dann auch
umsetzen da gab es dann welche wo der
fdp afrika ist da ja also das ist jetzt
nicht so für mich der berner aber das
haben wir beschlossen das wird gemacht
und das war für die beiden kollegen ganz
genauso deswegen auch davon mir
ausdrücklich dankt weil das macht ja das
arbeiten in der sache für uns haushälter
dann noch leichter
ja weil viele das wahrscheinlich auch
nachher fragen werden naja bei fricke
sie wollten doch sicher viel mehr sparen
und eigentlich noch viel mehr kürzen na
ja ich will das aber ich bin teil einer
koalition die eine vereinbarung
getroffen hat 12 und das ist mir sehr
wichtig für die fdp gilt immer noch der
alte grundsatz spare in der 2 dann hast
du in der not und das verstehen viele
immer nicht ich ärgere mich auch darüber
in den guten zeiten den wir da gesagt
haben hier noch mal weniger da noch mal
dass das war nicht gesehen hat dass das
die vorbereitung für die notzeiten ist
denn dann hast du in der not bedeutet
auch dass liberale und ich sage in dem
falle ampel haushaltspolitik bedeutet
dann musst du es auch tun dann musst du
auch haben in notzeiten dass wir nutzt
zweiten haben ist klar drei wesentliche
faktoren die uns daran hindern in diesem
haushalt die schuldenbremse überhaupt
einhalten zu können ukraine krieg corona
und ich sage das ausdrücklich inflation
wir haben gleichzeitig im haushalt dafür
gesorgt dass wir nicht nur
krisenbekämpfung machen sondern auch
vorsorge für die zukunft leisten das war
uns auch zentral wichtig dass wir gucken
dass wir die zentralen krisen es gibt
bei der klimakrise oder biodiversitäts
krise die sich noch verschärfen auch in
den blick nehmen wir wollen jetzt aktiv
handeln der krise wollen nicht dass wir
uns eine krise hineinsparen sondern auch
das notwendige finanzieren nicht mehr
und nicht weniger aber wir schaffen
gleichzeitig auch vorsorge für die
zukunft
wir haben jetzt in dem verfahren der
bereinigung auch dafür gesorgt dass
nochmal 200 millionen euro für
internationalen klimaschutz in
internationale biodiversität
bereitgestellt wurde um eben auch gerade
den ländern des globalen südens beim
naturschutz oder bei der transformation
ihrer wirtschaft hin zu erneuerbaren
energien auch zu unterstützen wir haben
geguckt dass wir auch zum beispiel die
schieneninfrastruktur nochmals stärken
der maßgabe schluss gemeinsam in den
haushaltsausschuss eingebracht also
haben wir der klar sagt dass wir wie im
koalitionsvertrag festgeschrieben
deutlich mehr in die schienen das in die
straße investieren wollen und auch die
bundesregierung dort aufgefordert beim
hauser 23 der finanzplanung das
entsprechend zu berücksichtigen und wir
haben für die nächsten jahre bei der
digitalisierung der schiene 400
millionen euro auch bereit gestellt an
verpflichtungsermächtigung damit jetzt
die großen projekte für die
digitalisierung der schiene auch starten
können uns war es wichtig alle drei
sicherheiten in den blick zu nehmen also
alle drei
potenziellen
großen themenblöcke auch vernünftig zu
bearbeiten
die innere sicherheit wir werden mit
diesem haushalt noch einmal die
bundespolizei stärken nicht sofort aber
für die haushalte 25 und 26 wird es
zusätzliche 2.000 stellen geben warum
haben wir dafür jetzt schon ein
haushalts vermerk ausgebracht damit
jetzt die anwärterinnen und anwärter
eingestellt und ausgebildet werden
können sodass dann 25 und 26 auch
wirklich das zusätzliche personal zur
verfügung steht was dann zum beispiel an
bahnhöfen für zusätzliche sicherheit
sorgen kann das war uns wichtig in
diesen zeiten wo viele über äußere
sicherheit diskutieren auch die
hausaufgaben im bereich der inneren
sicherheit zu machen wie haben die
katastrophenhilfe noch einmal gestärkt
insbesondere beim technischen hilfswerk
wo wir weitere logistikzentren schaffen
damit die bevölkerung im krisenfall
versorgt werden kann wo die einrichtung
des thw saniert werden und wir haben
sofort anschaffungs programm für unimog
für den thw auf den weg gebracht und ist
gerade deswegen weil das etwas war was
zum teil zum beispiel gefehlt hat und
wie auch aus den folgen dieser
katastrophe lernen wollten wir haben
natürlich die äußere sicherheit in den
blick genommen die verhandlung um das
sondervermögen laufen noch wir alle
hoffen dass sie zu einem positiven
abschluss kommen und ich hoffe auch dass
die union sich an der stelle ihrer
staatspolitischen verantwortung bewusst
ist aber äußere sicherheit ist ja mehr
wir haben insbesondere auch nochmal den
haushalt des
entwicklungshilfeministeriums in den
blick genommen und noch mal im rahmen
vom zweiten regierungsentwurf
ausgehenden aufwuchs von über 13 prozent
gehabt auf jetzt 12,35 milliarden um zum
beispiel die herausforderung der
ernährungssicherheit in den blick zu
nehmen etwas was uns ganz besonders
wichtig ist der konflikt in der ukraine
sorgt ja gerade dafür dass auch
ernährungs lieferketten zusammenbrechen
und am ende sind die schwächsten in
afrika diejenigen die leidtragenden
wären also haben wir das in den blick
genommen er muss noch mal mit dem thema
im stoff verteilen auseinandergesetzt um
sicherzugehen dass jedoch ein
impfangebot bekommt und wir haben das
umgesetzt was gestern auf dem g7 bei den
g7 beschlossen wurde bei den
finanzministern nämlich das 15
milliarden liquiditäts hilfspaket für
die ukraine darauf entfällt ein anteil
von einer milliarde auf die
bundesrepublik und diese milliarde die
gestern von christian lindner auch in
aussicht gestellt wurde haben wir heute
nacht noch in den bundeshaushalt
eingestellt so dass dann die regierung
quasi
auch sofort handlungsfähig ist und wir
haben und das ist meiner partei
natürlich nicht ganz unwichtig auch die
soziale sicherheit in den blick genommen
um es deutlich zu sagen wegen der
ukraine krise und wegen den
herausforderungen kroner bekommt niemand
weniger starts leistung wir haben
bewusst sichergestellt dass der
leistungsbezug weiterhin sichergestellt
ist und wir wissen natürlich im
gegenteil dass die inflation zusätzlich
herausforderung für viele haushalte mit
sich bringt und deshalb sind auch die
entlastungs pakete die von den ampel
fraktionen in den letzten wochen auf den
weg gebracht wurden auch vernünftig
etatisiert wurden